Captain Marvel 2 is rumored to be a
cosmic horror movie in the vein of
aliens in 2001 a Space Odyssey I am so
sick of this woke culture crap
what does aliens and mm want to space
out as you have to do with that what are
you talking about that's the kind of
style that the screenwriter said this
would follow oh it sounds cool sorry
once you say Captain Marvel I
immediately stopped listening in for my
own opinion didn't you vote for Bernie
got some random Captain Marvel to news
here from the website cosmic book dot
news Captain Marvel - scheduled to be
released as part of phase 5 the makuu
why doesn't one call that in 2022 you
rumor has it the sword organization will
be a central focus of the movie which I
know stands for the sentient world
observation response department the
rumor plot of the movie is that she's
supposed to be an agent for sword it's
supposed to assemble an a force to fight
against a cosmic threat I haven't
actually read the full article we'll
give our opinions as we go alright so
let's cleanse the air the air force wow
what a flogging in the Navy it's claimed
the air force members in cap to include
miss Marvel who's getting a Disney Plus
Series she-hulk also getting a Disney
Plus series and maybe in spider-man 3
Spider room and it's rumored Feige wants
to develop a character scar which yes we
know Mighty Thor Valkyrie and Spectrum's
uh-oh Oh Monica Rambeau
oh that we pretty cool if they got the a
force going and you'd have all these
rising predominant female characters
yeah birds of prey meant and then you
combine them into their own mashup movie
it could give you a different type of
mashup in the MCU to get excited for
outside of just another Avengers
Assemble kind of flick that's that's
pretty neat yeah you can make a whole
movie out of that one shot from endgame
ladies ship
rumors offer secret evasion Disney Plus
series is being developed and will be
tied directly into Captain Marvel - it
said that The Secret Invasion series
will explore a group of scroll refugees
hiding out on earth or pursued by
squadron or Kree sleeper cells led by
yon rogue and the remaining members of
Star Force who the main character will
be hulking a crease color bread who has
taken the identity of Teddy Altman a
normal high school student this is a
crazy specific really cool sounding
rumor if you ask me yes sound pretty
cool and I mean the secret Wars of
famous can you get a Secret Invasion
show and that's something that people
wanted to be explored more in Captain
Marvel I actually think would be a
pretty neat thing to get on a Disney
Plus series yeah man or agents of shield
the leaker a guy urinating on the
streets claims this film will deal with
this sword and base being compromised by
a rare alien threat the threat is the
brood who are laying eggs on the sword
base and possessing agents it turns out
that only male operatives can get
compromised I don't know if I believe
that which leads to the formation of the
a force what is that comics accurate
someone someone come in to go down below
that just sounds lower date cookie yeah
only two men Carol and the other female
heroes of the Marvel Universe must stop
the threat of the brood and their
influence across the galaxy turns out
that the species are operating as
parasites and have been secretly
conquering planets in the universe as is
pretty neat in order to kill them they
must kill the Empress brood which means
going to their home planet yeah remove
the head that sounds like a whole lot of
sci-fi things that could also be really
cheesy yeah on paper this sounds
ridiculously corny but super fun at the
same time all I want is this to start
out as alien and then turn into Starship
Troopers by the end and I will be
satisfied 150 look at SAC although in
some ways because aliens was one late
80s Starship Troopers capped off the 90s
even though this is just a rumor it
sounds like the kind of
I would really enjoy a lot yeah what
would fans like it Oh No cuz it's
captain Marshall but I mean it would
depend on the cheese it would depend on
it cuz you know people do take issue
with Marvel's sense of humor so I feel
like if they could match it to the 90s
and and properly filter it through that
eras aesthetic the right way I think it
could work yes good the potential leaker
finished so Meghan MacDonald the
co-owner of McDonald's Omega McDonald's
that CEO and an EE ll also writer of one
division has pitched the sequel as
heavily inspired by aliens and 2001 a
Space Odyssey and almost that's what we
have to really lean in here almost a
cosmic horror movie to borrow from
aliens I feel would be cool 2001 a Space
Odyssey as well the thing though is is
those two movies when I see what they're
referencing in terms of their script
tonally and stylistically I could see a
version of any film if you said it's in
the vein of aliens in 2001 Space Odyssey
right I could see any movie like that
when you read the plot description I'm
like I don't get a lian's or 2001 a
Space Odyssey tonally is what I'm
talking about so I'm having a hard time
kind of wrapping my brain it's really
apart yeah like a more paranoid viral
outbreak yeah isolation movie at least
until they get to whatever planet they
need to actually sound something more
like something Joe Cornish correct okay
yeah yeah yeah I'm wary of any mention
of horror now with Marvel when they I
saw the headline I was like well how
cosmic horror are we talking about
because you just typed up Doctor Strange
for being super horror and then they
acted back off that ledge to extensively
not being that horror II I'm always
curious now as to what they mean by that
and how much they want to stick to it
and yeah going with touchstones like
aliens and mm want a Space Odyssey are
kind of funny to me because also just
Marvel movies aren't scripted like that
unless we're gonna get a fifteen-minute
you know colors and trippy symbolism
montage at the end of this you know like
2001 is a very deliberate kind of film
and I feel like the tone of that movie
kind of exists within its form right
right so it's an interesting set of
touch tones and yeah based off the plot
description I'm not really seeing it
here but maybe that'll make it more
interesting maybe to see that plot with
those tones will you know create that
alchemy that's true a force and the
ambulance emancipation captain purple
finally spin that team movie off of you
make enough money to do so yeah if any
of these rumors are to be true I feel
like it would be pretty neat we just did
a video about daredevil potentially
being in spider-man 3 and this article
does go good point out that G hook is
also one of the rumored characters
because they're both lawyers what
excites me about is mashup though if any
of this is to be true is that Miss
Marvel and she-hulk will have their own
TV shows and they would have a chance to
immediately cross over into one of the
movies as opposed to the thing that we
always wanted with you know at least a
good amount of those Netflix Marvel
characters Danny ran to eventually go
into one of the Avengers movies and that
never happens but also be a good
business module overall to entice people
to go watch those shows as well I don't
know about a Spider Woman being
developed this is actually the first
time I'm hearing about this and pretty
much out of the loop on that for Spider
Woman to be introduced in here I think
would be a neat addition Scarlet Witch
Mighty Thor and Valkyrie they make the
most sense I think out of all the women
who would be teaming up here I think the
one you really got to get rights would
be spectrum the older Monica Rambeau
which would be cool but then that begs
the question though this is probably
down the 90s now right maybe like at
least not on earth nineties if she's
older and then the fact that you also do
have these other characters if they are
doing the whole a force it would not be
in the 90s yeah yeah now have to be at
least the 2000s this actually sounds
pretty awesome in a lot of ways
depending on how you do the balancing
act of it they could pull it off it does
sound like a lot though to throw in a
movie in actually a movie that needs to
make some headway on its
characterization you're already
introducing the concept of sword
maybe that is part of what Nick Fury was
doing at the end of far from home the
thing about this rumor is this actually
sounds plausible and the fact that the
writer came out and said that they are
doing something kind of in the vein of
cosmic horror that would make sense it's
really the a force thing that I'm having
the hardest time believing they're
actually trying to develop even though
brie Larson has in the past campaign to
want to get like a female superhero
team-up movie but at this point I'm like
why not just make it any force movie
yeah yeah oh yeah to call it khanseb
Captain Marvel to Captain Marvel and the
a force or something like that yeah get
it in the right direction so you have to
retitle with me but hey I'm always a
little gravy hey I'm always a little
wary when they're like hey we're gonna
introduce a whole new team in this movie
but right now there are ways to do that
and it would be rad to see all these
characters - I just yea hope that if
everybody complained about warming up to
Captain Marvel that they really don't
get too distracted with all this extra
stuff and really focus on her yeah what
do you think about this do you want
Captain Marvel to to go the airforce
route does cosmic horror excite you
who'd you vote for
sir if they're leaking these things
because they can't put movies they're
probably wondering if they're allowing
these to come out just so that you can
be likes to keep thinking of us
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell hey let's end this
with a eric horseman eric has been
having kind of a rough time as a lot of
people have got a message from him today
John wrote you her true story yeah pase
pase work of book this is the tale of
Eric the horseman
gay is a maypole and her lips as a
Norseman he went out one day to go see
his shrink and along the way stopped for
a drink the horse - man Eric oh he was
hammered Eric the horse demon was drunk
so he took off his pants saluted the
room and dropped his pipe class with a
clunk on a vendor now was Horstman the
eric no end in sight to this garish
nightmare until there in the street
shown in the young glow buzzing like a
grinder match in the snow with his pants
still off and his cheeks shining red the
anxious Horseman swilled his head he
marched right inside his money in hand
and said give me works and make sure
thread the clerk said okay but like what
do you want eric stood jump struck he'd
forgot the wasted Heric rattled his
brain but all that remembering it was in
vain with a sigh the horseman sat and
said just give me whatever that is
throwing his finger to the left and the
clerk replied that's not our design
that's just this really awesome youtube
channel I watched to which Eric replied
am I paying you to chatter am i paying
you to talk Eric heard that'll be $700
as he blacked out of sight and at this
point that tattoo guy was too tired to
fight down said the artist with a sigh
and his hues and that's the story of
Eric's Rio rejects tattoo
so thanks Eric horsemen I hope things
get better for you